bei uns im studio ist aus dem
unterhaltungs restaurant mark pittelkau
der siegfried und roy lange lange lange
begleitet hat wirklich sehr sehr gut
kalkar erkennt und kannte wichtigste
frage wie geht's siegfried aktuell
tatsächlich also momentan geht es
siegfried natürlich sehr schlecht das
ist klar im angesicht des todes und mit
sehr körperlichen schmerzen die
möglicherweise auch da sind es ist
natürlich für ihn nicht leicht aber er
ist glaube ich in einer mentalen
verfassung dass er sehr gefasst ist er
weiß dass er sterben wird und lässt
natürlich so ein bisschen revue
passieren sein leben und hat nur
gegenüber freunden auch gesagt er hat
ein schönes leben und er schließt
versöhnlich mit diesem leben ab was
sagen die ärzte genau also warum linke
sterben was ist seine krankheit also bei
siegfried ist im november
bauchspeicheldrüsenkrebs diagnostiziert
worden was ja einer der aggressivsten
krebsarten überhaupt ist und man hat ihn
dann auch gleich ins krankenhaus
gebracht wo er operiert wurde der tumor
wurde entfernt aber es musste leider
festgestellt werden dass er gestreut hat
der krebs hatte gestreut und die ärzte
mussten ihm die traurige mitteilung
machen dass er nicht wieder gesund wird
und dass er nur noch wenige wochen zu
leben hat muss man tatsächlich so sagen
und das war natürlich ein schock aber
siegfried hat sich dafür entschieden
nach hause zurückzukehren und dort zu
sterben und was nachvollziehbar ist weil
er natürlich dort wahrscheinlich über
auch dort immer noch nahe ist weil sie
dort sehr lange zusammen gewohnt haben
mag dass die beiden ja seit 25 jahren
begleitet habe ich gelesen erst als fan
dann ein separater was hast du denn
heute empfunden als sie die nachricht
gehört sie war sehr geschockt muss ich
sagen aber auf der anderen seite hatte
ich in den letzten monaten immer das
gefühl dass der siegfried sich vom tod
seines besten freundes räumen nicht mehr
wirklich erholen wird die beiden waren
so eng zusammen und es war ja wiener
ehepaar muss man sagen mit höhen und
diesen nicht nur beruflich auf der bühne
das sehr erfolgreich waren sondern eben
auch diese private verbindung magische
verbindung die sie miteinander hatten
das ist ja das was man sich sofort
fragte wenn man wiener ehepaar so lange
miteinander das leben geteilt hat wir
kennen das aus dem freundes- bekannten-
kreis der partner verstirbt nach so
vielen jahren dann scheint das leben in
dem moment keinen rechten sinn mehr zu
ergeben ich glaube so ging es siegfried
auch er hat das nicht so raushängen
lassen sage ich mal wenn ich habe
zuletzt mit dem er im sommer telefoniert
da sagte er dann auch dass er ja immer
um sich fühlt und es war tatsächlich so
die haben ja zwei kleine häuser gehabt
und ein gemeinschaftshaus das war alles
fußläufig konnte man da zueinander gehen
und und die haben jeden tag miteinander
verbracht und war natürlich durch seine
behinderung der handy gibt aber da hat
siegfried hat ihnen immer sehr gepflegt
also seit dieser unfall 2003 passierte
an den tiger in gebissen hat war es
schwierig räuber sehr eingeschränkt
nicht nur in seinen bewegungen auch er
muss das starke medikamente nehmen
es war sehr schwierig und oftmals war
natürlich siegfried seine eigene seine
größte stütze und immerhin aufzubauen
das kann schon gesagt er ist aktuell
nicht im krankenhaus erst zu hause du
warst ganz oft bei ihm wann zuletzt weil
zuletzt war das vor 22 jahren also im
dezember 2018
das war in der weihnachtszeit da hatten
wir den achtzigsten geburtstag von heino
gefeiert hat ist ja die beiden sind auch
irgendwie freuen ja sehr eng befreundet
und hannelore und da waren wir zum
kaffeetrinken eingeladen und das war ein
sehr sehr schöner adventsnachmittag es
war die beiden liebten weihnachten und
und es war natürlich dementsprechend
geschmückt sie waren ja auch sehr
religiös und ich glaube auch das ist für
siegfried jetzt sehr schwer war dieses
weihnachten ganz alleine zu verbringen
gerade bei der der weihnachten geliebt
hat nicht dabei und ich habe mir das
auch ich habe weihnachten viel an
siegfried gedacht weil ich mir
vorstellen konnte das ist für ihn kein
schönes fest war und jetzt ist eine
bewusste entscheidung dazu offenbar zu
hause sterben zu wollen davon gehe ich
aus er könnte natürlich jetzt auch in
ein hospiz gehen er hat natürlich auch
das geld sag ich mal dass er sich eine
pflege leisten kann wie auch häuser die
sich schon geleistet hat in den drei zu
den 17 jahren in denen er ja die
behinderung hatte ja das hat unmengen
von geld verschlungen und siegfried
hatte zuletzt oder hat momentan einen
priester bei ihm der in jeden tag
besucht er hat zwei hospiz schwestern
bei sich die rund um die uhr bayern sind
also erst nicht einsam
das ja ist schwer zu sagen weil ich
einsam aber er hat jemanden der sich um
glaube ich glauben können dass das licht
was er jetzt sieht und die hoffnung die
er hat und die freude die möglicherweise
in ihm drin es ist dass diese freude
dass er glaubt roy bald wiederzusehen
das hat er ja auch schon geäußert als
roy gestorben ist und untreue hat er ist
in einem video was er noch zu lebzeiten
aufgenommen hatte als überraschung für
siegfried was erst danach in seine hände
kamen was dann auch auf seiner facebook
seite veröffentlicht wurde hat er gesagt
ich warte auf dich und ich werde dir die
größte show bereiten die du jemals
gesehen hast und wenn man weiß wie groß
diese flora das noch zu toppen durch so
ein
emotionalen satz der dann weiß man auch
beide glaubten oder anderen leben nach
dem tod mag stichwort größte show ich
muss zugeben letztes jahr gestorben ist
habe ich die beiden das erste mal
gegoogelt ich bin ja ein bisschen jünger
als ihr 2 und deswegen haben wir auch
eine maz vorbereiteten film und mal zu
zeigen was die beiden eigentlich alles
im leben erreicht haben ich muss sagen
ich konnte letztes jahr gar nicht mehr
aufhören mir alles über die beiden zu
ergoogeln und anzuschauen weil es war ja
einzigartig und das wollen wir auch
ihnen jetzt einmal zeigen
ihre zaubertricks mit weißen tigern
lassen siegfried und roy zum
erfolgreichsten magier duo der welt
werden eine karriere geprägt von
superlativen stern auf dem legendären
hollywood walk of fame wahl zu den
besten magiern des jahrhunderts ihre
shows in las vegas in über 25 millionen
menschen weltrekord die ersten schritte
als zauberer sind allerdings noch recht
bescheiden mit 17 zieht siegfried
fischbacher von zu hause aus und führt
seine tricks auf dem passagierdampfer
bremen vor hier trifft er auf roy horn
fortan treten die beiden gemeinsam auf
startschuss für ihre außergewöhnliche
karriere bildet mitte der 60er jahre
eine tournee durch europa 1970 lang sie
in las vegas was folgt ist eine
beispiellose karriere der zwei männer
die während ihres gemeinsamen weges
privat von einem liebespaar zu freunden
fürs leben wurden ende der 80er jahre
unterschreiben siegfried und roy ein
vertrag mit dem mirage hotel denen eine
summe von 57,5 millionen dollar
garantiert damals der höchstdotierte
vertrag in der geschichte des live
entertainment
kein geringerer als michael jackson
komponiert und singt den song zur show
die siegfried und roy show' im iran bei
der 27 weiße tiger mitwirken avanciert
zur erfolgreichsten show in den usa 2001
erhalten sie von mirage einen vertrag
auf lebenszeit doch nur zwei jahre
später geschieht dann das was sigrid
schon lange befürchtet hatte mai wird
während eines auftritts vom tiger
montecore angegriffen und
lebensgefährlich verletzt überlebt ist
aber teilweise gelähmt und die bühne
zeit der beiden magier kommt zu einem
abrupten ende
ihre liebe zu den tieren allerdings
nicht so leben die beiden gemeinsam mit
zahlreichen wildtieren bis zur ist tot
im mai 2020 auf ihrem anwesen in las
vegas
[Musik]
mag man hat gerade gesehen dass du auch
ein kloß im hals zeit ist und sehr
ergriffen bars ist die maz lief
natürlich mit eurer gemeinsame historie
was hat denn die karriere von den beiden
so einzigartig gemacht
man muss wissen dass als siegfried und
roy 79 in las vegas anfingen waren dass
er zwei exoten also den ist gesagt
worden mit wilden tieren hier auf der
bühne zauberer
das funktioniert denn das vegas nicht
und haben da keinen dort drauf gegeben
und dann haben die beiden aber sehr
klein angefangen also noch nicht mit
einer großen show wie man sie zum
schluss kannte sondern im kleinen shows
hotels mehrfach gewechselt wo sie
aufgetreten sind und haben dann
tatsächlich den nerv der zeit getroffen
und haben eine neue ära in las vegas
eingeleitet des showgeschäfts das gab es
vorher noch nicht vorher gab es dann
halt die großen sänger da ist ein track
sinatra aufgetreten und jetzt standard
plötzlich zwei leute die auch rein
äußerlich schon sehr auf fielen durch
ihre kostüme und mit mit wilden tieren
und das hat sich dann das hat sie so auf
die leute gewirkt dass es dann wirklich
an weltweit ist die leute sind aus der
ganzen welt sind nach las vegas gekommen
um siegfried und roy zu sehen und über
über jahrzehnte waren die beiden die
attraktion von las vegas und die stadt
hat den beiden viel zu verdanken
viele sind nach las vegas geflogen und
sie kreuz und ich 19 95 das erste mal
aufbrechen wollte sich roth hernals
verbuchen wenn man das so sagen kann
ohne die schufa ich hab die auch nur
kannte die auch nur so aus ausschnitten
und war natürlich völlig fasziniert ja
das sind jetzt die tage du hast das gilt
gerade geschlagen bedeutet in denen du
wahrscheinlich auch noch mal ganz viel
aus diesen gemeinsamen zeit mit wie
siegfried und roy revue passieren lässt
würdig was ist der eine ganz besondere
moment der eine ganz besondere ist
berührenden moment besonderer moment der
dir im gedächtnis bleiben wird für immer
mit ja das wird da gab es mehrere es war
natürlich immer schön
die haben halt auch am anfang als wir
uns noch gar nicht so gut kannten immer
nach der show mich empfangen also auch
dann ging es hoch in die garderobe die
haben ja noch garderobe gehabt ich war
so groß wie eine eigentumswohnung oder
also wirklich fast wahnsinn und jeder
hat seine eigenen bereich und es gab
auch da diesen bereich für alle wo dann
die tiger tatsächlich dann sagte dann
ich zeig dir mal hier wo ich mit meinen
tigern meditiere und da sagst dann
tatsächlich so
das war ein löwe weiße löwe securities
der und den haben sie dann raus guten
gesagt damit die auf der couch die ganze
zeit und dann haben sie eine flasche
champagner aufgemacht und feuert sein
whisky getrunken und es war ein lustiger
abend und irgendwann ist der löwe dann
wieder in seinen jeweiligen in die
garderobe von rolf verschont es ist wahl
diskutiert also mit den beiden zusammen
zu sein war sehr skurril und danach in
den jahren danach war ich auch oft mit
wenn diesen preis bekommen haben und und
das waren und sind ist heute helden auch
wenn roy schon verstorben ist die las
vegas auch nicht vergessen wird
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren